je vous propose de continuer et on va
monter au premier étage
malgré les apparences ces étudiants
versailles et ne sont pas venues faire
du tourisme en première année de classe
préparatoire scientifique ils ont la
chance unique de découvrir les locaux du
technocentre de renault
une visite dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'industrie est une opportunité pour
eux de faire leurs premiers pas dans le
monde
encore inconnu de l'entreprise c'est
beaucoup plus ludique et pédagogique
pour nous que de balayer des défis shayk
des métiers des choses qui ne parle
c'est beaucoup de concret nous dit
beaucoup quand on va arriver en
entreprise tout ce qu'on a appris va
changer on va apprendre beaucoup sur le
tas et si ça permet d'anticiper un peu
cette période là qui peut faire faire
peur parce qu'on en arrive en entreprise
jeune on peut penser qu'on qu'on connaît
tous et en fait pas du tout dans les
couloirs du technocentre la trentaine
d'étudiants observent écoutent et
interroge aussi pour la première fois
depuis 2001 l'industrie française est
redevenue créatrice d'emplois l'an passé
et le secteur automobile est l'un des
plus performants du secteur
ces jeunes qu'on reçoit aujourd'hui
c'est potentiellement les ingénieurs de
demain donc potentiellement ma relève
donc c'est toujours intéressant de leur
présenter nos métiers il ya beaucoup
d'opportunités dans l'automobile en ce
moment et donc je pense que il faut
communiquer là dessus et leur dire
qu'ils sont les bienvenus pour tenter
d'attirer les jeunes talents le
technocentre a accueilli 250 élèves
durant cette 8e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie
en ile de france près de 700 événements
étaient organisés au total